well I go back to that baseball has had
its been in a state of denial for a long
time in 2003 the survey year they did
not anticipate crossing the five or
seven percent threshold that would have
triggered mandatory testing their
position was we don't have a problem
baseball we certainly don't have a
steroid problem in baseball particularly
they subsequently went on and in fact
the lair reduce our night they went with
two of us and maybe at that point said
they didn't have a stimulant problem of
baseball either I guess all of us who do
about greenies didn't quite understand
how they came to that conclusion the
cost of all that in caminetti and
Canseco and so on obviously the house
govern Reform Committee under the
leadership of davis & Waxman now Waxman
Davis had hearings and I testified at
those hearings and I pointed out some of
the specific deficiencies that existed
and there were many what's happened with
baseball is a reaction each time there's
some sort of expose is another increment
towards their program the program is
constantly getting improved increment by
increment my position has been and
remains to this day and I think senator
Mitchell came to the same conclusion I
said in the low five hearings and
congress at baseball or to get out of
and i stayed the same for the NFL out of
the anti-doping business and hand it off
to an independent transparent
accountable agency that they could not
do this with in-house they had to
externalize it outsourced it if you will
they've done what they have done is take
the the the world anti-doping code and
incremental have taken pieces of it the
satisfied
critics I guess such as me and others I
say this is not a matter of
incrementalism this is a matter of
taking the entirety of the code which is
was developed by an international
process of governments and sporting
bodies from all over the world
tremendous amount of effort went into
this thing led many cases by athletes
who wanted nothing more than the
opportunity to participate in sports on
a level playing field didn't come from
some ogre you know some bureaucratic aim
really the initiatives came from
athletes and make that the program for
Major League Baseball to this day they
will not do that since so every X number
of months there's a they've opened up
the collective bargaining agreement
which until the next issue of doping
arose they have never opened up its
collective bargaining agreements but
they opened them up and they've made and
tweaked and change things and to show
how disturbing it is the literal report
for example pointed out there was
roughly 100 cases attention deficit
disorder suddenly emerged that was after
I made the case that stimulants was a
problem of baseball they reacted by
banning some stimulants all right and so
because their therapeutic use exemption
program left something to be desired
suddenly all of a sudden was an epidemic
of attention deficit disorder which is
treated with stimulants so the ad the
baseball player who would have gotten
ding for taking a stimulant says oh I
have a DD here's a note from my doctor I
have a DD so now I can take the
stimulant well that was in the footnote
in the Mitchell report the night no on
and on they'd have to take chapter in
verse to do it to do it justice but the
answer is get out of the business do
exactly what the IOC did remember they
were out there since the 1960s and then
they really what the leaders in this
field they created the field and they
finally threw up her hands and you know
what no matter what we do we lose no
matter what we do
we lose we got a totally go independent
will be part of that process will have
fun that process but we're going to stay
out of the line of fire of all this
decision making stuff baseball can't
possibly right there we shouldn't expect
baseball to do what the world
anti-doping agency does we shouldn't
expect baseball to spend hundreds of
man-hours playing an annual list
together of prohibited substances that's
not their expertise their expertise is
to feel the great game of baseball and
deal with the contracts and length of
seasons and all those things it's not to
deal with the hardcore science and
implementing implementation of any
doping initiatives that's not their
thing if you asking why they've been
resistant they can only speculate and my
speculation relates to sanctions and the
sanctions in beige league baseball has
its own evolution as the first hearings
in Congress when they recently said
there's going to be X number of days or
$10,000 find and little bird or showed
up and and so they had to change that
the issue of sanctions for a major
offense is currently two years and it
made as may go up to four years under
the new code which goes into effect next
year I think they'd rather be there
probably quite concerned and some of
their super stores they wind up out of
the game at least for a couple of years
I can understand their apprehension
about this but if you're really serious
about getting doping out of your sport
then you're going to bite the bullet
there's no easy way out of this thing we
know that history is taught us that over
and over and over again so they need to
do what they need to do if in their
heart of hearts they want to get doping
out of the sport that same goes for the
other professional sports the United
States as well not just baseball
well it turns out you know the role of
government at all this has been rather
significant whether it was the president
in the State of the Union or whether a
reclassification of anabolic steroids or
other investigations like the BALCO
affair or whether it was the hearings in
Congress there's no question that more
came out as a result of the
congressional hearings than anybody
anticipated Major League Baseball the
National Football League changed their
programs substantially that would not
have happened in my judgment had there
not been in those hearings in other some
people and congressional side of the
table caught up with the celebrity of
all of this but for the most part I
thought the questions were probing and
insightful and I think baseball at
football recognized they were in an
untenable position they tried to respond
by incremental changes in hoping
Congress and everybody else will go away
and say all right you fixed it over
kaput done it turns out now the probing
continues every time something happens
is another question and so I think it's
a it's holding their feet to the fire
and I don't think that would have
happened without congressional
investigation I I fully understand
there's big problems in the world but I
also recognize when we talk about the
number of kids that were using these
drugs that's a men that national concern
and so I think it's appropriate for
Congress they're built with
so that reminds me of debating societies
and that's great Potiphar somebody wants
to have a philosophical debate i'm much
more grounded in here now and the
realities of what's happened in the
abuse of drugs with my concerned and our
drugs are getting more and more
sophisticated more and more dangerous in
some regards more and more insidious in
some regards and that we have to deal
with that I've clearly obviously heard
these discussions